In my lab we study how people and animals move and in particular how the nervous system interacts
with the biomechanics of the body in the environment to produce useful movement
and in particular we study balance control as well as walking.
My parents were born in China and went to Taiwan where they grew up
and then came to the US for graduate study.
As a child we spoke Chinese at home. I spoke English at preschool and then when
I was five we moved to Italy and I learned Italian,
so I've been speaking multiple languages and doing a lot of translating
throughout my life and I think that actually translates really well to what I do today
in bridging seemingly different disciplines.
I have a number of students and postdocs, they come from all sorts of disciplines,
from neuroscience from mechanical engineering, from robotics and biomedical engineering.
In college I chose mechanical engineering partly because I wanted to be an astronaut
and was interested in space exploration and aeronautics and things like that.
I met a graduate student in robotics who pointed me to a biology professors lab
where I ended up spending two or three years doing research studying
actually how insects move and the principles that we found have actually been used
to develop six-legged robots that are able to walk on complex surfaces.
But I ultimately decided I wanted to work on something a little bit more directly applicable to human movement
and particularly to rehabilitation.
Now with the advent of robots that you can buy off-the-shelf, we can actually think
about using robotics to assist people with gait or balance impairments.
A lot of my insights about human movement come from the fact that I like to do a lot of different sports
so this understanding of how muscles work together in groups
both because of the way neurons act together as well as how they act on the biomechanics
has been one of our major contributions to science.